This is a whole story, but like I discovered, discovered, for me, I discovered conditioning
I didn't know what that was.
Also, hairbrushes.
These are just essential components of my daily life now that never existed for me prior
to a year ago.
Just like all these things that women have just been doing for so long.
The single biggest recommendation that has been life-altering for me came from Nate,
believe it or not, of all the various people who've given me comments, and it was, don't
fucking wash your hair, but once a week.
Because I've washed my hair every day of my life for my life.
I don't even wet my, I won't wet my hair, just like a little light wet for like almost two
weeks.
Wow.
And it doesn't get, it doesn't get greasy.
Like, I would imagine maybe if you started this, and especially with maybe your guys' hair,
it's a little straighter.
Yeah.
It would get greasy.
But mine is like, I don't need to do anything to it.
And when I do, it gets dry and frizzy and just sticking out.
You're at a different level, man.
Huge.
So I can see Caddy wondering right now.
It's like, look, every time I'm on this thing, we talk about our hair for the first 15 minutes.
Does this happen when I'm not here?
I don't know, right?
Sometimes.
We got to get John on TikTok.
What's our own TikTok?
What's our TikTok?
Are there your TikToks?
I just need you to like, realize conditioner on TikTok.
I just need you to like, go do a TikTok where you're like, conditioner.
And there's like some viral thing going and you're just like, whoa.
I could give you like a whole routine and you would come back here just being like, mind
blown.
I would be gorgeous.
You would be like, just, yeah.
You'd be Fabio.
I'd be so pretty.
It'd be like, it'd be ridiculous.
I want to be that pretty.
I really do.
Okay, well, we can start on your skin next if you want.
24 is a doozy.
And I was just like, I know, I mean, I know we always all do this, but it's just about style,
isn't it?
Like, it's at least the way that I've talked about it.
Like, it's just totally about that, you know, in addition to being a very straightforward
critique of Hegel, right?
Like, you know, so just in terms of our conversation and Nate's projects, it's like, I don't think
it doesn't even, it doesn't mention Hegel, but the whole sort of refusal of contradiction
or the diagnosis of contradiction and negation and how it works.
And Nietzsche is being taken up here entirely in terms of the non-Hegelian, right?
That's, that's the function.
Nietzsche gets taken up on 173 and Hegel gets a mention right before that.
He basically says, you know, to the top of 173, it is not difference which must go as
far as contradiction as Hegel thought and his desire to accommodate the negative.
It is the contradiction which must reveal the nature of its difference as it follows the
distance corresponding to it.
And then he turns to Nietzsche to think about, you know, the positivity or the possibility
of difference or disjunction being affirmed.
Yeah.
And I mean, at a, at a structural level, I mean, that is the, the main difference between Hegel
and Deleuze is just right there, you know, I mean, for, for Hegel, opposition is primary
to difference and produces difference as its effect.
Whereas for Deleuze, difference is ontologically primary and any kind of opposition or contradiction
is a secondary conceptual move by a person or an individual, you know?
So that, that, I mean, that is a nice little schematic there that, that Deleuze lays out.
I would have liked a little more, uh, on Hegel, but that's okay.
Yeah.
You know?
Well, I mean, I think John's right.
The whole thing does seem to have Hegel in the background.
You know, I mean, he was brought up the one time explicitly.
Well, I liked the way that this got spatialized a bit more in thinking about distance and distance
in relationship to, um, contradiction.
And I mean, you know, tend to think about distance as, as a, as a negative.
It's just something that doesn't, you know, exist except for the, that here it's, I mean,
it doesn't exist in the, you know, in the sort of like substantial sense of existence,
but as a, it is a positive distance is a positive relationship that has particular effects.
And there are different distances and even contradiction as a style of difference or a
style of distance.
Deleuze is the guy who installs the Nietzsche v Hegel idea.
And, and Derrida doesn't share that, you know, Derrida, I mean, glance is all about, you know,
Derrida is fascinated by Hegel.
Um, and, and I mean, I get like, I increasingly get a sense like this, to me, this, this series
is actually pretty good, which is like Hegel's right at the level of bodies.
Um, the level of, and the level of actuality, right?
Like that's, I mean, that would be another way of interpreting it, right?
Like that Hegel's right at that level, but, but that's a kind of superficial meaning non-surface
for him, right?
Like a superficial non-surface level where the interesting stuff, the event is what's happening
on the surface.
You know, again, he's messing with the, the depth surface metaphorics there, but yeah.
I mean, right.
Well, talk about saying the same thing, you know, in different ways.
I mean, how many of these series are, are, are, are trying to think about the two, like
the, the relationship of, you know, incorporeal events and their specific relationship to, you
know, the depths of, of bodies.
And I wonder, I wonder if this is not more systematic than we give it credit for though,
because I actually, I mean, here's the thing.
I'm never going to do this, but I do kind of get the sense sometimes that one could go
back.
I do get the sense that there are, there are threads from like, for instance, the earlier
the manifestation denotation stuff that he leaves off for about 10 series and then takes
up again.
Right.
And there's, and you see it like 24 and 25 are really a good example.
Cause at one point in 25, he's like, I think we've shifted the question.
Let's return to the question of the, the commensurability of events.
And, and that's exactly what he did.
So it's, I wonder if this is not more of a systematic ontology than the, first of all,
the way we're reading it, but also the density of the writing.
It's very difficult to get that kind of, for me, certainly to get this global view, but
there are phrasings occasionally that make me think, oh yeah, he did say that somewhere
back 80 pages ago, but I don't really remember it.
I'm not going to go back and look at it.
There are a lot of, I increasingly think that, that there are a lot of, either like he's
bringing up concepts or questions from earlier series and then readdressing them, or he's
like doing that very explicit signposting.
Like, you know, the, the, the, this is the very first line of 25.
It seems that our problem in the course of our investigation has changed altogether.
And it reminds me a whole lot more of say, like Austin's How to Do Things with Words.
Like there's this series I'm going to, I'm going to take, you know, this one line as far
as I can and say like, you know, five to eight pages.
And then that'll spur me off into something else, spur me off into something else.
But then, you know, like six, seven series later, that's going to pull me back to an earlier
distinction and re situate it, remobilize it.
And, and, you know, so there is like there, it very clearly is like a lot of communication
between these different series.
But yeah, you know, it, they're, but that's not, they're not all sort of operative, independent
on themselves.
They're not like, you know, the, the, the plateaus.
There is a difference between that, that plateau style and the series style.
The plateau from the, I do find, I find the writing to be more systematic in these later
series, like even just standing alone by themselves, like the way he's articulating becoming and
the affirmation of becoming and that movement seems fairly systematic.
Now it's obviously very abstract and you're not going to be able to wrangle like a, you're
not going to be able to wrangle a Wikipedia entry out of a lot of these concepts, right?
Or like some sort of general gloss, but like, I don't know if that's the right.
That's part of the point.
Like you're not supposed to be able to get a Wikipedia entry on quasi causality.
I wonder, for instance, in terms of the Wikipedia question, like this is again, the thing that
I'll never do, but I actually feel like if you wrote down the definitions of all of the
terms, they would actually line up, right?
Like, you know, I mean, so quasi quasi causality is the relation between events.
Well, that's exactly what it was eight series ago, right?
Like, and so now what quasi causality is in relationship to necessity and destiny, like
That gets elaborated here that didn't, didn't come up earlier, but actually that's what I
mean.
I feel like the terminology and I agree with you, unlike The Thousand Plateaus where I feel
like there is a kind of a paratactic or differential use of the terminology here.
I kind of feel like, um, yes, there is communication among series, but I sometimes get the feeling
that there's a transcendent order, right?
In, in the sense that like all this shit really did get laid out on a plane or, uh, you know,
and, and then he's kind of sliced it up in, into its series here, rather than the series
being the way through which the plane emerges.
Yeah.
Does that make sense?
I totally follow that.
I don't, but I don't think that's necessarily the case just because, I mean, you know, if you
think about The Thousand Plateaus, you know, the way that those plateaus communicate to
each other through, to each other seems to be much more based on disjunction that.
Yeah.
I agree.
There are, you know, like the distance that spaces out, you know, the terms and the way
that they come back to each other, you don't, they're not, they don't totally conjoin with
each other.
And even when it's the same language, you know, body without organs here, they're, they're
doing different work in different places.
Whereas here, I don't necessarily think that it was transcendent and then sort of like
stylistically, he, he cut it up in order to be like cool and edgy, but that there's a
much more sort of like a speculative or provisional way that he's working through these things that
yes, they're like, it's not to say that they're all consistent with each other, but they do
conjoin with each other.
Right.
Where it's like, you know, the, the, the term later on in the series is definitely a development
of something beforehand, but it's development isn't single and linear because it's had to
pass through a bunch of other terms and other things to arrive where it's at.
But it's, I mean, maybe the difference is that he marks it here.
Whereas like the, the, the different occurrences of body without organs, it's not like he'll
say in chapter four, like, unlike what we said about bodies without organs in chapter one,
here we see something else or, you know, here it is, that is done.
Like he marks like, okay, this is the way we were talking about it several series ago,
but we miss, but we left something out.
Right.
So could you say that in some ways, The Thousand Plateaus is him taking something like Logic
of Sense and then going back on it and subtracting the conjunctive tissue in order to create,
I mean, not just as a stylistic element, but as a way of creating con or disjunctions out
of what were more conjunctions.
Yeah.
Or it's just, it's just a more, it's more, it's just feels more paratactically generated.
I mean, and maybe that's because there were two people then because, and I, by the way,
I don't believe that he had this architecture, general architectural principle in mind and
then cut it up afterwards.
But it does seem to me that as he's writing through it, he is thinking architecturally as
well, which doesn't seem to be as, as much the case in, in Anti-Oedipus, but Anti-Oedipus
or A Thousand Plateaus, but those seem way less systematic to me as well, which is why
you can read any one individually.
You know, he says like, you can take any plateau and, and read it on its own or read them in
different orders.
And I don't think that that would be as true here.
You know, like you can't, you couldn't just read, uh, these, these series in different
orders because they presume one another in ways that is not as true in A Thousand Plateaus.
So you can see this is developmental.
Like he still has that sense of, um, continuity functioning underlying here.
And he, he, he gives it up.
He, he Beckets it there, you know, though.
It's not foundational and that he doesn't like come in and explain all of the terms and
the foundations early on and then work from there that I think that we would, you know,
if we went back and read to say like the first five to 10 series, a whole lot of stuff would
click that didn't click before.
Yeah, I think you're right.
He sort of like, he's mobilizing a lot of these terms in fully developed articulations, which
isn't to say that they're still, they're the same as they are later on, but they're like,
he's not taking a lot of the time to explain.
He's mobilizing terms and then their mobilization and like their expression, you know, as they
start to encounter each other, reshapes them as they move along.
Right.
So it's not representational in that way.
Yeah.
I agree.
I've also been really, I've been really struck by, and I, and I, and I, for thinking about
this at like architecturally, I've been really struck at how I've come to predict in the
reading of each series, the structure that seems really repetitive.
I don't know if you all have kind of gathered that, but I, at this point with every series,
I expect that the last paragraph is going to go off the rails.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like, like, I remember like the 18 series, right?
It's where we have, you know, the, the fogged window pane and everything.
I just, I always expect with these series to go just somewhere else.
Um, somewhere that, you know, is related, but is also bringing up God and, and eternal
connection and chronos all of a sudden.
Right.
And it's like, I, I'm curious about that too.
Like why the, why the leap always at the end?
Have you noticed that?
He was already a part of the golden age of the television series long before it struck
us.
You have to have the last thing, the last, you know, two minutes have to be the curveball
that set up the next installment.
Right.
No, I was just saying, I think that's really interesting.
Like, I just kind of expected that.
And that was, that's also the first appearance.
So, you know, Guattari, and I read this book and I really liked it.
It was called, it's called Chaosmosis and it's just by Guattari.
And I thought, well, that notion of a chaosmos, that was Guattari's, but it's here, right?
I mean, this is, so, I mean, that surprised me.
I was like, oh geez, Chaosmosis.
I didn't realize that that, that Deleuze used that term prior to, I mean, this is well prior
to the joining with Guattari.
So.
Interesting.
I also wonder how much of this is like my, me getting more familiar with the rhythm of
the text or it's the text itself developing further as the series go along.
Cause I, I find that as these series, they seem to be more abstract later, right.
And kind of more difficult to read, but actually experientially it's easier for me to digest.
And maybe that's just a function of like getting used to the book.
Getting used to the concepts and getting used to the thinking.
I mean, that's, that's one of those things that's just so, you know, you just can't say
that enough to grad students.
It's like, this is, this is work that you just have to live with.
Like you, you just, and I'm not saying that there's necessarily a good reason to
live with it, but, but, you know, if you really want to get it, you just have to spend a lot
of time and, and it will, it'll, it's like, I mean, I was acclimating to an idiom was always
the phrase that I use.
And I gave the analogy of like, you know, when you go to like, when you go up to the mountaintops
in Colorado, like some people get sick, right?
Like genuinely sick and it can last for days, you know, and it can, you might not get over
it, but for most people, if you just stick around, things will start to click, you'll
get over it.
And I find that to be true for all of the thinkers that we're engaging, right?
Like it's, it's, it's not, it's not page turnery.
It's not, uh, you can't digest the information as quickly and easily.
You have to kind of live with the idiom for a little while.
And then it starts clicking and you're like, oh, this is, even though the topic, I agree
with you, the topics are becoming more and more sort of esoteric and, and yet it's actually
easier for us to read.
It's, you know, not going to be so great for us.
It's also, it's, it's easier and it's also expansive because I don't know about you all,
but I, because I've been kind of dwelling in it, like just off and on for so long, I can
read something like distance is at arm's length, the affirmation of that, which it, which it
distances.
And I see at arm's length and I'm immediate, I'm, I'm, I'm immediately like inserting the
body and the body's mixture that creates sense into that sentence that, you know, for, for
all I know, I mean, like that's just a translation hiccup or something.
Right.
Um, but, but because I've been living with it, it's like, oh yeah, body sense, boom, you know?
Um, so I think that's really interesting too.
Very expansive.
Yeah.
And it's also a question of just what you can do with the text as well.
Like you're, you're saying like, maybe it's a translation mistake, but if that mistake works
for you and your project, then, then run with it, you know?
Immersion in the idiom truly is key.
Like when, when people who've never read philosophy or are not in the field talk about how weird,
like the way we talk is, I'm like, it's the same as learning German.
Or something, you know, like any, you wouldn't expect to hear a German lecture for the first
time and be able to understand it.
And so like, it, it kind of works the same way.
My, my buddy who's also a listener, long time listener of the podcast.
Um, conversation.
A friend of the podcast.
Yeah.
You know, he was, we were talking about the difficulty of philosophy and, and, you know, he kind of
brought up the, um, you know, if I were a quilt weaver or if I were good at quilt weaving or
whatever it is, then, you know, no one would be surprised that, you know, that I have some
kind of like technical vocabulary, lexicon or whatever else, but it's, it's a threat when
it's philosophy and, you know, he, he brought, he effectively brought up, you know, like the
sort of philo's technique distinctions.
Like, well, no, like, like there, you know, if a technique is like a, an isolated body of
knowledge that, you know, you expect because it's sort of, it's, it's foreign to me and
I have to go there to then like, you know, develop it.
So I go to a new place.
It's not all that surprising that it takes me, uh, uh, time to, to figure something out,
but because philosophy is always sort of dealing with effectively the logic of something that
feels very domestic, feels very intimate to me, it's far more threatening.
The things that, you know, we, we, we experience, you know, phenomenologically all day, every
day, you know, you mess with those, then, then defense mechanisms, you know, start to
get raised.
Like, well, if it pertains to me and these really intimate ways, talking about myself,
my identity, my, you know, experience, my capacity to think, then, you know, I better be able
to understand it.
And if I can't, then clearly it doesn't pertain to me because if it's me, then I must understand
it.
Right.
Yeah.
That's actually perfect for what we just read.
I mean, if we're thinking about connection and communication as, as one, as an identity speaking
to another identity, then, then we don't, you know, that's bullshit.
Right.
Um, it's, it's more, again, it kind of goes back, yeah, it kind of goes back to style.
Like how, what is the style of that expression?
Well, it can't just be identity to identity.
Right.
It felt, it honestly felt like very, um, prescient of like a lot of, a lot of critiques of social
media where it's like, Oh, just social media is just, um, it's just self-production
rather than building community and building connection.
It's just the compulsive self-production and self-egotistical bullshit.
Right.
Um, this kind of felt.
Let me, let me also say, I've never really understood that critique of social media.
I mean, it just, on the face of it doesn't make sense to me.
Right.
The, the, the critique is that this is a bunch of ego centered folks just sort of showing
who they are.
And I'm like, I mean, I don't spend a lot of time on social media, but that's just not
the case.
I mean, again, it doesn't take a sophisticated analysis.
I mean, it is, it is obviously an unequivocally community-forming in some way, right?
Like that there are collective, emergent collectives from, from these various types of practices that
are not simply of, like, me too.
Right.
Um, so I, I just have never, that has, that critique has never really made sense.
Like, it's like the selfie critique, you know, um, that these are just people who are interested
in the sort of narcissistically looking at themselves.
And, and that's, again, I mean, I'm not a selfie person, but I know people who are,
and they're not like that at all.
And that's not the function of the selfie either.
Right.
So I, I just never, I mean, maybe it's just an easy thing to say as a way to just, you
know, criticize something, but it has never made sense to me.
So, but it just shows how, how not just deep, but ubiquitous the logic of representation is,
is that if you see social media as like the representation of a prior self, then it totally makes sense
why that's narcissistic. And, but if, if you're operating from the position that I think that y'all
are operating from, you're saying one's self-creation in a social media space or one's, you know,
self-creation and with the selfie is not self-creation at all, or it is the act of creating a self
and not representing a self. And it's a transforming, it's an exposure of the self to some kind of
difference, to some kind of alterity that is going to now produce, you know, a transformative
exploration of distance. Yes, exactly. It's an exploration of distance.
Exactly. Like that's what it is. Yeah.
So, I mean, that, I mean, that's a good, that's a good way of saying it. Instead of an affirmation
of self, it's an affirmation of difference in the sense of the difference between myself and other
self, you know, or, or whatever it is, you know, right.
Yeah. Yeah. I, but that, but it's just, it's not just, you know, because we tend to think of,
of, you know, the representational logic of communication in terms of its technical aspects.
I'm like, ah, it just doesn't work the way we think that it does. But this introduces a whole
line of the, the, the, the, the moralizing of representational logics. Whereas, you know,
it's just yourself, therefore it's narcissistic, therefore it's bad. And to overlook the transformative
qualities.
One of my bug bears in the field for my career for 20 years has been, there's a kind of disinterest
in a problematizing, and if to say it nicely of the notion of a self in the interest of a notion
of a kind of collective. And I've always felt like those were bad poles, right? Like you're given bad
alternatives because it's not a question of one versus 25 because 25 can be as much an individual
and one can be as much a collective, right? So to me, the issue is much more, is one thinking
in a unified sense or is one thinking sort of experimentally? And that's, that difference is
a difference for a group or for a person. I mean, it doesn't matter how, how big that thing is,
but I do see a recurring, like within, within humanistic scholarship, there is a kind of,
you know, the individual is bad and the collective is good. And, and, and that's just those,
to me, those terms are, they're just way too coarse. They're way too stark of terms and it doesn't
actually deal with the dynamics. And that, to me, this is better at that insofar as it takes like
the distinction between the individual and the person, right? That's, that's one of the,
one of the ways. And, and to your point, Nathaniel, one of the things that I like about this that I have
a hard time with it, because my tendency is to want to say, fuck representation. It's always
illocutionary, you know, always. But what he does is he says it's both, right? Like there is,
there is the representational relation at the level of contradiction of depth and surface and actual
events. But there's also, you know, there is also the illocutionary, you know, which is at the level
of surfaces and events that is both embedded in and transcendent, you know? So, I mean, I, I,
it's hard for me to really get my head around that and to, because my tendency is to want to like
pick the illocutionary team, if that makes any sense, um, against the representational team,
but he doesn't, he doesn't do that. This is, in some ways it's like more traditional and it gives
more away to the Hegelian position, uh, than, than I would want to, you know?
Well, I mean, whenever Deleuze, when he's not critiquing representational logic and when he's
thinking about representation as a possibility, you know, he's always going to amplify the
importance of that prefix re, you know, I think in the, his context, it's like the important thing
about representation is the prefix re, right? Which means that it cannot do the thing that we
think that is doing, that there's an intensification, there's a transformation,
there is a difference, there is a distance, you know, there has to be. So, you know, if you're going
to think representation, then you have to think distance, which means you can't think
failure or fidelity. Right. Gotta take a jab at Nate. Well, you can. Never miss an opportunity to
take a jab at Nate. But, you know, this series is the, called the, the, you know, the 24th series
of the communication of events. And how much does he talk, talking about communication here,
and how much does this have to do with understanding, meaning, representation? Like,
really not at all. Not, not at all. I mean, it's, it's, and I want to get into this a little bit,
because I want you guys to help me through this, because I really, for instance, one of the things
that I quite like, well, first of all, I love, I'm not sure what to do with the affirming destiny
and denying necessity, right? Like the, that paradox, which is like destiny, good, you know, necessity,
a problem. But more, for me, the notion of expression, that there's an expressive rather
than a causal relationship. I mean, and that's pretty early on. Like, on the one hand, event
effects maintain a relation of causality with their physical causes, right? And then we got
that before, the depth and bodies have causal relationships to the events, without this relation
being one of necessity is rather a relation of expression. So that on the other hand, they have
between them or with their ideational quasi cause, no longer a relation of causality, but rather once
again, and this time exclusively a relation of expression. And so what the word expression there
means, again, I do, it's, it's quite different than the, what the word expression means in our field.
So if in our field expression means, and I'm taking this from the elbow esque, right? Sort of compositional
duration. It means a preexisting totality expresses its itself in a representational way. And regardless of
what it says, it is presenting in a convention, it is presenting itself. So expression as it's used
in our field is, it's not, it's, it's not representation, it's presentation, right? And there's
no re, it's just pre, it's just presenting. And in, and in this case, expression is not a presentation,
like what, you know, or rather, maybe I'll just ask it as a question, like, what do you guys sense is the
difference between an expressive relation between the kind of quasi causality of events, and, and
something like representation or something like causality, right? I mean, how is expression different?
That sounded like a teacherly question. I didn't mean to sound like that.
I don't think that expression expresses causes, I mean, sorry, effects. I think, I think that's the major
thing. So if you think about the cause effect relationship, then you have to say that a cause
contains within itself, the necessity of an effect, right? Right. That's right. Right. And, and, and there
you're getting to the issues of totality that, and this is why, you know, cause effect relationships are
so hard to find and isolate because you'd have to say, all right, in order for this relationship to
be causal, you know, the totality of the effect needs to be located within causes. And there can be no,
It cannot be mere correlation at any level, right? Right. Whereas expression doesn't seem to effect a
determinant thing, but it seems instead to shoot out forces in different directions that can then get
caught up with other things and can get mixed or, um, or, or communicate with things, but it's not,
but, but there isn't, you know, there's, there's, there's, it lacks the teleology. There's, there's
not the, you know, the, the, the, the oak tree inside the, inside the oak. The sense of a, the sense
of a deterministic unity. That's why I love, I mean, I'm definitely the one takeaway for me from this,
I'm definitely going to start using the word instead of causal compatible, right? Like compatible and
incompatible, you know, it's not that this caused that it's that these two things are compatible.
Um, and that's not, that's also not core. It's something stronger than correlation. It's not
just saying these two things happened in some vague proximity. It's saying there is a relation,
uh, between them that is a, to talk about something being compatible. You're saying like it works well
together, you know, or it doesn't work. Yeah. I mean, yeah. I mean for, this is where Leibniz is really
interesting because you know, the move that Deleuze is making with Leibniz is one to say like, look,
Leibniz offers this incredible contribution and saying, what stop thinking about cause and effect in the
relationship to possibility and impossibility. And let's start thinking about compossibility and
incompossibility saying like, all right, how, how do different features of a, um, can be expressed
within a world with a certain kind of consistency. And you know, there can be an infinite number of
worlds and infinite number of permutations of the worlds, but not all worlds are compatible with each
other. Um, and for him and where Deleuze says that, um, Leibniz is coming up short is seeing, um,
well, God acts as a kind of limiting device, right? In the same way that I think Hegel, like that God
acted as a limiting device for, for Hegel, by the way, that sort of, you know, sets a kind of transcendent
order, uh, an RK over, you know, the operation of what would otherwise be a kind of unlimited
heterogeneity in order to make sure that, you know, like compossible things, um, you know,
can conjoin or they don't have to, but you know, the incompossible, um, uh, um, incompossible
entities, you know, there is that, that is articulated in the negative that, you know,
they just point to, you know, the, the incompatibility of things. So you can't have X with Y
and Deleuze vis-a-vis Nietzsche's contribution to that say like, no, the incompossible is just
a different style of conjunction of compossibility. And what it does is it takes, you know, if,
if compossibility reduces the distance between things to zero, then incompossibility or disjunction
just takes the part, like the, the, the distance between something, whatever it is, and sees it
as a specific positive attribute to the relationship between.
That's the affirmation of difference. So that ironically, the incompossible is the God term,
right? The dis, the disjunctive is in fact the organizing or the, rather the disorganizing,
but the, the ontological principle here that's primary is disjunction, not conjunction, right?
Yeah. You can also say, well, I mean, can we think through the difference between saying
conjunction is just a style of disjunction and disjunction is just a style of conjunction?
Right. I mean, that's, that's, I mean, but he does, he goes through those syntheses and
I remember, I mean, this is a, you know, a precie of the Anti-Oedipus, the syntheses of
Anti-Oedipus, but he goes through these syntheses and I remember thinking, oh, the and, you know,
and is going to be the good guy. And it turns out it's not right. It's the or, the disjunctive
one that is the more interesting of them because it is the sort of the affirmation of difference
relative to the conjunctive, the conjunctive one. So.
Well, so I think you could articulate, you know, I mean, I, I'm going to answer my own question
is that you can say it both ways. You could say that, look, disjunction is just a style of
conjunction in that disjunction is, isn't incompatible, that disjunction, like disjoint or disjunctions
are sets of relations. But then you can say the opposite and say that conjunctions are just styles
of disjunctions, which is to say that no things simply conjoined, that even a space of zero is
still a space, it's still, there's still a difference of affirmation there.
Right. There's, I mean, if you allied self, you have to allied self-identity because that's,
that's the problem with the conjunctive is that, is that taken to its extreme, it's self-identity,
you know, and, and it wants to say like, there's, there's, there isn't that, that's the theological
point, you know. Forget about saying that X equals Y, X doesn't even equal X.
X doesn't equal X. Right. So, you know, I mean, and that's, and that's like, you know, I mean,
that's where what's interesting to me is he does also want to hold on to the notions of logic and
not just say logic is a product of a disjunctive, of disjunctive syntheses. He wants to say logic
does its own kind of thing. Right. And it, and it operates and it's totally functional, you know,
at the level of bodies and depths and, and, and their relation to events. It just doesn't apply to
events, you know. I've been thinking, I've been thinking about expression and events and, and how
those two, well, I've been thinking about compatibility specifically in terms of infinitives.
Like to me, that seems like to affirm a positive distance is to allow for an infinity of, of
infinites. Right. Am I, am I. Well, this is where he pulls in the two logics of time. Right. Because
one of the, like the level of the surface, it's all, it's the operation of the infinitive and at the,
at the level of the, um, depths of body is, is the, is the infinite partition. Right. But if we're
talking about communication and we're trying to communicate positive distance that lives at the
level of sense of, you know, at that topology. Right. Um, so to affirm it is to then maybe attempt to,
to speak all the infinitives. I don't, you know what I mean? I, I need to find, I just need to find
those passages to sort of, well, the infinitive stuff that is on the bottom of 70 and 71, where
he takes the example of the, uh, whatever the, the animal, the, the beetle or whatever it was,
the butterfly, the butterfly, the gray butterfly. Right. But a species of butterfly cannot be at once
gray and vigorous. Either the specimens are gray and weak, or they are vigorous and black. We can always
assign a causal physical mechanism to explain the incompatibility, a hormone, for example, on which the
predicate gray would depend so that, you know, and that's how biology works and which would soften or
weaken the corresponding class. And we can conclude from this causal condition that there's a logical
contradiction between gray and vigorous. But if we isolate the pure events, we see that two turn gray
is no less positive than two turn black. It exposes, it expresses an increase in security to be hidden,
to be taken for bark of a tree, as much as the becoming black is an increase of vigor to invigorate.
Between these two determinations, the two, the two turn gray and two become black between these
two determinations, each one, each one of which has its advantage. There's initially a relation of
primary event mental incompatibility, uh, physical causality inscribes the incompatibility only
secondarily in the depth of the body via hormone or whatever. And the logical contradiction translates
it only in the content of the concept. In short, the relations of events among themselves from the
point of view of an ideational or nomadic quasi causality first expresses non-causal correspondence,
illogical compatibilities or incompatibilities. The Stoic strength was in committing this themselves to
this line of thought, according to what criteria or events, etc, etc, etc. Astrology was perhaps
the first important attempt to establish a theory of illogical incompatibilities and non-causal
correspondences. So, you know, I mean, I, I take that to be like, that's, that's an example of what I mean,
right, where he both says, he's saying two things. One is, yes, at the level of bodies,
you can assign a hormone to be the causal determiner of gray versus black. And at that level,
there is an incompatibility or a, an opposition between vigorousness and gray, right? Like at that
level. But at the level of the infinitive, which is at the level of, I mean, in his terminology,
the sort of becoming or the event, the event of these things, it's just a question of differences,
you know, so that, that gray is more compatible with vigorous, whereas black, and so it's not a
question. So that's what's interesting is both of those moves, you know, to be able to say,
yes, at the level of bodies, you can say hormones cause this or genetics or whatever it is, right,
like cause this behavioral difference, which produces an opposition. But at the level of the,
the event of the becoming gray or black, there isn't an opposition, there is just the differential
expression. And, and there's equally say gray or black at that level of the infinitive, you'd only
have to be able to say graying as graying. That's right. Yeah, right. Which is not a question.
So the becoming gray, becoming invigorous, becoming camouflaged in the tree are sort of like movements
that are, that are more harmonious, harmonious becomings that, you know, blackening and invigorating.
But you, or rather, I mean, and to me, I think you would say gray is not in becoming invigorous. It's
becoming hidden. In other words, it, it's not that it has an opposition to the question of vigorousness.
It's just not on its radar. It's just not compatible with that thing, right? Only from the perspective
of the assigning of a genetic or hormonal or whatever biological causal mechanism would you say,
hey, here, this one's vigorous and this one's not vigorous, as opposed to this one's hidden and that
one's vigorous. Those are just different, uh, you know, those are different sort of compatibilities
of, of the infinite. Just are different speeds of movement. Being hidden, being vigorous is not
particularly great for being hidden. Exactly. I mean, exactly. So the vigorous thing is, is not
becoming unhidden. It's just its own difference, you know? So that's what's, uh, that's, what's
kind of interesting about, cause that's not only an, it's kind of an explicit critique of physical
causality. And the critique is that it's not materialist enough that they think the scientific
kind of classifications are actually too conceptual and too reliant on the taxon taxonomy. Whereas
Deleuze's ontological framework is aiming to attend to the real differences that kind of,
you know, make up the butterfly. So here's a, here's a taxonomical question is, could you create a taxonomy
that had no negative words in it? So it wouldn't be vigorous and invigorous? So it would be vigorous
and hiddenness. And you'd have to, right, you would have to be an entire spectrum of, you know,
wouldn't even be spectrum. And my question is, wouldn't hiddenness be a form of vigor? Or is that relying,
again, too much on that? You'd have to take a different sense of vigor and then abstract
it above to govern the polarity between, right? Right.
Vigor without the asterisk mark.
And, but that's, and, but think about it, what's built into that is what comes, you know,
several pages later, which is not raising to the level of opposition, right? Between the, in,
and he's, you know, introducing that idea now. And that, that that's one that just always makes
so much more sense to me. And that's like, opposition doesn't make sense to me. It always
seems really coarse and really reductive whenever you think in any situation of two things as being
opposed, right? Like even when it's a fricking game of sports, right? Where like you have what are
called opponents, you know, playing against one another, um, that, that the notion of opposition
always seems like two, yes, at the level of the result. Yes, I get it. It is, you know, um,
one team against another team, but at the level of the actual game, it doesn't seem like that,
right? It's, it seems like there's so much more and so much messier going on that, for instance,
it's really good in certain circumstances to give up certain types of things in order to gain other
kinds of, you know what I mean? So that, that, that notion of opposition, like the gray butterfly is
opposed to the black butter, is opposed to the black butterfly on this question of vigorousness.
It's like, no, they're not opposed. They're just different manifest, different expressions,
right? Of to butterfly. But this is what's so interesting about what this is doing with
logic here is rather than trying to introduce, you know, an RK or an overlying logic that's going to
to govern all of this, or say logic is broken, let's chuck out the windows and like, look, as a
particular style of action in the world, you know, logic does a whole lot of stuff. It just doesn't
have a privileged place in the relationship to everything else. So, you know, it, there's a
difference between saying there are oppositions from that transcendent, transcendent perspective
that will sort of like create a pure difference between, or pure oppositional difference between,
and as opposed to installing oppositions contingently here and there that now create
kinds of relationships, right? So, you know, what happens when the other player becomes opponent
and, you know, sort of like a certain kind of opposition then gets run out that can never maintain
itself, right? As it would never be a transcendent opposition. It would be a local deployment of,
you know, like two opponents.
Right. And that's, I mean, it relates back to our broad considerations as well. I mean,
I'm just thinking of Nate thing, but like that sense of, if you really do take relationality to
be primary, opposition doesn't make any sense at all, right? Because that's just one type of relation
among others. But, you know, thinking sort of like if the ontological primary category is
relationality, then it is always me with the ball in relation to the person, the other person in front
of me with the ball. Like that's the primary category, not me and my attributes of Kevin Durant-ness
then going out into the world. It is Kevin Durant in the last two minutes. It is Kevin Durant,
you know what I mean? Like if it's always primarily relational, then the, then opposition just doesn't
really make any sense. It's just a question of responses to, you know, different expressions,
I think would be something like the terminology.
Yeah. I mean, it's like, it's, it's, it's a changing of space in the expressions, right?
It's, um, it's, it's realizing that you have the power to, to bridge, to, to, to form space,
right? Between the infinitives that will then necessitate a different kind of connection, right?
I mean, again, like you're saying that the problem doesn't seem to be
logic or opposition in themselves. I mean, clearly, maybe at a superficial level, they do work
in the world and they still do operate as conceptual categories. Um, but the, the issue for Deleuze seems
to be the hyposta, hypostasizing of, of logic or of opposition where you have faith in those categories
and you're not attending to the, the more primary or ontological differences that, you know, uh, that
make up those relations. So that, that's his call basically for not only, this is where, sorry,
I'm a little bit jumping all over the place, but the, this is where I feel like there's,
there's two aspects to the affirmation of becoming one is it's an ontological principle,
right? It, it's not that it's out there in the world, but it's how events express themselves,
like we're saying, but it's also, um, a philosophical orientation, right? Maybe not a choice of the
philosopher, but it is some sort of, right? He wants to facilitate, uh, some kind of attention to,
uh, that affirmation, correct? Well, that would do something other than the Hegelian position.
So if you thought of it in like the Heidegger versus Levinas terms, right? Like where Heidegger
as ontology is first philosophy and, and Levinas is ethics is first philosophy. Um, they're both wrong,
right? Like, I mean, in, in that sense, and I think Derrida, I think many thinkers sort of share this,
which is ontology is ethics. Um, but, but ethics isn't morality, right? You know, it's, it's not that,
that, that reductive and that simple, but yes, I mean, what is with quotation marks around is,
is always an enactment of relations and enactment of response. So therefore it's never about ontology
being first, nor contra Levinas of ethics being sort of prior to, to being, you know, it is always
sort of both simultaneously in those terms. So I think, yeah, like there is a, there is an investment
in like, Hey, attending to, uh, life in this kind of differential way presents differences, right?
Like it, it offers and not better, right? Like, I mean, I think that that's important. And also it is
where for me, like, as Nathaniel just pointed out, he's hanging on, on, I wouldn't do this. Like if I
was writing something like this, I'd be like, see, the logical relation is bullshit. And it is all about
the infinitive and the force of the infinitives. Like that is my inclination, but he doesn't do
that. He's like, no, the logical relation is one kind of thing. And it is actually an action in the
world. Um, but so too, is this other thing. And as Nathaniel said, like, it doesn't have primacy of
place. Like it doesn't have, it is not that organizing principle. It is just one mode of response.
Right. So it is back to style, you know, like it is, it is, I mean, I think about that quote on,
on, on 179, where he says, you know, my love is an exploration of distance, a long journey,
which affirms my hate for the friend in another world and with another individual. And so in that
sense, there's a choice of expression of the infinitive of love there, right? That's a, that's a,
that's a love that will extend. It's an invitation to other, to other, um, infinitives,
you know, and thereby, thereby producing an affirmative distance.
There are, there, there are compatibilities and incompatibilities, right? And so that's where the
question for him is always, I mean, you know, any particular event, uh, not that you could recognize
it as such, but is it a disjunctive or conjunctive? Like how, how does it work? What sort of compatibilities
does it foster or cultivate what sort of, um, incompatibilities does it foster? And the
question would never be compatibility, good incompatibility, bad, just like it's ridiculous
to say, you know, gray butterfly, good, you know, black butterfly, bad. It's just differential responses,
right? That's where the ethics ontology question has to get like, I mean, I, the butterfly metaphor
squashed, right? Like you gotta, you know, I mean, it really, it really does so that it's neither ethics
nor ontology, nor even a synthesis of the two. Um, right. But that, I mean, I, I take that to be,
that is the thing that is what the thinking of the event is. Well, Nathan, you know, said earlier,
the problem with some of this is that, um, you know, the sort of empirical orientation isn't
material or empirical enough. And, you know, I was thinking about that in, because it's so indebted
to logical taxonomies, right? Yeah, that's right. That's, that's is this, this is that, and then it
sort of relies on the promise of that taxonomy. But, you know, let's think about, well, I'm sorry,
I have a, I have a cheesy visual example that's gonna, you know, work very well on, on a, on a podcast,
but I, you know, I've got two things in, in, in different hands and then, you know,
they are opposing right now they're pushing against each other, but it has absolutely nothing
to do with what either object is. One's a cup and one is a coaster. And the fact that they're pushing
against each other, you know, it's their opposite. They're, they're opposed to each other in a
particular way, you know, for a particular moment. And that opposition isn't essentializing at all,
but it does create different things that it creates, you know, for one thing, if it, if I do it long
enough, it creates fatigue in my muscles. But, you know, like to think about opposition as,
you know, as, as something that emerges from a series of relationships that will then always give
way to another series of relationships is so different from the way that we think about opposition
as constitutive of, you know, the essence of a thing.
I mean, that's Hegel, right? Like that's the whole machine, you know, is, is unity of opposites. And we
just, you know, we didn't finish the book, so we didn't get to the unity part. Right. But we had
lots of individual, I mean, he says that really, I mean, this is, you know, where that, this is the
last part. I mean, I, we're trying to stick with 24 just because of Nathaniel's shortcomings as a
human, but this is on 175. So this is where he does the Hegelian version. It's not, so we just did the
version that interests him, but the version that doesn't interest him is on, is on 175. And this is
the Hegelian where like halfway down the page, it is necessary to distinguish two ways whose personal
identity is loss, uh, two ways by means of which the contradiction is developed in depth. And this is
the Hegel. It is, it is through the infinite identity that contraries communicate and that
the identity of each finds itself broken and divided. That's pretty straight Hegel. This makes each term
at once the moment and the whole, the part, the relation, and the whole, the self, the world,
and God, the subject, the copula and the predicate. I mean, that's, that's straight.
Hegel. Right. But the situation is altogether different at the surface where only infinitive
events are deployed. Each one communicates with the other through the positive characters of its
distance. That's where the disjunctive, right. And by the affirmative character of the disjunction.
Yes. Right. So, so, I mean, so on the one hand you have the Hegelian story and the Hegelian story
is a story of, of, I mean, in some ways it's a story of unity and multiplicity, but of a very different
order. Uh, insofar as it's a story in terms of actuality, um, and, and, and bodies and states of
affairs. And that is, the, the self merges with the very disjunction, which it liberates and places
outside of itself, the divergent series of so many impersonal and pre-individual, uh, singularities.
That's sort of like the idea of a, the liberation of a disjunction, sort of like the body becomes
the possibility or the event becomes a possibility for the liberation of the event. Right. That's,
that's fascinating. I mean, counter-actualization is already infinitive distance instead of infinite
identity. Everything happens through the resonance of disparance, point of view on a point of view,
displacement of perspective, differentiation of difference, and not through the identity of
contraries. I mean, we're all, we're all reading. We all didn't say we were all. Yeah.
Well, this is good shit. I want to keep going.
What, what I, what I like there is that it, it both is and is not bodies, right? Like, I mean,
in other words, you just, you're able to maintain, I mean, you have this kind of dualist, for lack of a
better word, um, vision here where on the one hand, like you have the relation of actual things that
actually does operate according to the Hegelian moves. Like it really does. It's right, you know? Um,
but at the same time, it's, it's missing everything that there is. I mean, that's where Nate's comment,
I think is right on. It's, it's like, it's not material enough because it, it's like, it sticks at the
level of identity and actuality and it, and it misses the evental, um, what it's not even structuring
quality because the event doesn't, the event isn't causal, you know? Right. Well, it misses that
complexity. I think the one, the one thing is like for Hegel, the eternal return wouldn't be able
to be like imminently expressed through the individual as it's, as Deleuze seems to want it
simply because it's, it's the primary presupposition, right? It's always kind of like bubbling within you,
but it can't be actualized because of the, like, right. Conceptuality for Hegel is a reductive
apparatus, right? And if that's the case, that's his basic like principle, right? And so the materialist
position that Deleuze takes up wouldn't be possible for Hegel because of the reductive mechanisms of
the self of, of identity. But you have to give him, so let's give, let's give Hegel credit. Like, let's,
let's just say, um, conversely, you would have, let's say the cosmological version of the eternal
return. So yeah, Hegel is not, um, Hegel's not saying that any individual like ever achieves the sort
of absolute, the notion, the absoluteness of the absolute spirit, right? Uh, but cosmically,
cosmically spirit does, right? And so, that, that would be the sort of end point, you know? And
that's why talk of ends, ends of history, ends of things, it really resonates in a Hegelian register
because you just say, so, I mean, that's the cosmological version of the eternal return is,
you know, it's billions of years is the sequence of things that returns, meaning not like your
lifetime or this moment. It is, it's, it's a billion year. And so, and this is a vision that
informs, I think a lot of physicists' versions of the universe of expansion, contraction to less than a
point and then infinite expansion to the size of the universe and then infinite contraction. Like
that's an eternal, that's eternal return thought as the return of identity, right? So such that the, uh,
and hence the investment in like the origin of the universe, like if we really understood how all
matter and energy was concentrated in a single point, we could at least theoretically, deterministically
play out every version of all things that ever happened, right? Like that thinking is very much,
that's the unity of opposition and difference, you know, that exists at that nascent point. And you
can have a notion of eternal return and people read Nietzsche this way, right? They say like,
well, Nietzsche's eternal return is, is a cosmological principle. And there's a lot of his writing,
you know, unpublished writing that supports that. That's like, he's thinking of this in, in those ways.
And I mean, what, what Nietzsche, I mean, what Deleuze does is he's like, look, effectively all that ever
returns is disjunction. Like that's the, that's the thing that returns. Right. The event is the thing
that returns and the event is not a thing. So what one is willing and willing the eternal return is not
the return of an identity identity, like us doing the exact same thing. Um, but, but the eventness of the
event, right? Like, so, and, and so therefore the eternal return is, it can be for this thinking,
it can be nothing but the return of difference. So there's never a question of an origin in which
all things would have been contained or an end point of heat death at which all things must return to
that origin point. Right. The, right. The alpha and omega stuff just doesn't, it doesn't work here.
You know, I mean the, the one, just one more thing about, I mean, we can keep going on this, but
he seems to characterize Hegel as a thinker of identity, which is true, but I think it's,
he's a little bit more, I mean, the way I would phrase it is he's a thinker of the compulsion
towards identity. So he doesn't essentialize identity or opposition, right? He's the thinker of how
these structures inhabit us and force us to, to act and think certain ways. And I, and I get that
to lose wants to disrupt that, but I do feel like not, it's not a major straw man here, but I, I do feel
like there's, there's portions where he mobilizes Hegel as a humanist thinker. Whereas I think there's,
there's a little bit more complexity to his particular dynamic to the dialectic.
Well, I think that, you know, Hegel is a thinker of identity insofar as he's a thinker of the undoing
and perpetual movement of identity. Right. And that, I think that was, you know, like one of the big
things that we sort of developed a relative comfort with in, in the Hegel tapes. But to go back to our
initial phrase here is like, this all comes down to style and the mechanism of, of movement of the,
the do the, the, the creating and undoing of identity is that of identification and the production
of its opposites where, which has such a close relationship to understanding and knowledge and
Representation that, you know, identities, you know, like the movement of identities can be captured
in sort of these, these representationalizable points and oppositions. And no, like Hegel would
say like, look, don't trust him. Right. Because, you know, Alf Hegel is not synthesis. It's not just
another point that, you know, that there's, there's such an over, there's, there's such a fracturing
or an overabundance of all of these representations that you don't, you can't trust any one of them.
But it all has this really, really tight relationship to, you know, understanding representation.
Whereas the kind of communication that's happening here through disjunction for, for Deleuze just seems,
is, is not opposed to understanding or representation, but it's just not on its radar. It's just like,
is, is, is not even part of the apparatus.
It's just a blip. Like, so that's where to me, like, yes, let's, let's start with the premise that Hegel is a
thinker of movement, right? Like, I totally agree with that. And, but, but I think, I mean, I'm with Nathaniel
on this because that movement is organized around identification. And so, yeah, friends, Hegel is the thinker of
the moment is both a moment and the totality of all of the movement, right? Like it is, it is both the
and a moment in the realization of spirit. And that, that thinking would never work for any moment of
anything for Deleuze's ontology, right? Like a moment is just a moment. I mean, that's all it, all it can
ever be. So now what it means for it to be a moment is a pretty complicated thing. But one of the things
it's absolutely certain is it doesn't contain any totality, right? It is, it is not, there is no sort of
underlying built-in thing. It contains lots of movement as with Hegel. It's just as the movement goes wherever it
goes. And, you know, it's not, it's like there's a sort of internal guardrails for, you know, your term of
contingency, which is opposition, right? Like that, that, those are the guardrails. Like you have to get to
opposition to have interiorization, self-transformation. And it is, it's perpetually
self-transformative. That's, that's super clear. So it's not static. It's not a static sense of
identity, but it, but it nevertheless is really organized around, I mean, this is, this is like,
how do you get to the event? Counter-actualization, you know? In other words,
the non-actual or something not actual about the state of affairs, the event, I mean, event is the
word here, you know, for that, which is not actual in states of affairs.
Which I, could you say is that's just, that logic is only operative at the level of the event. So like
oppositions don't exist except for they are installed as sort of invents and then create
quasi-causes and then like do a whole lot of bunch of stuff, but they don't like, they don't exist
substantially. Also importantly, they aren't transcendent descriptions of, you know, already
existing sets of relations through the introduction of relationships into sets of relationships. So
like to introduce an opposition into a series of relationships is just to add another variable
into those sets of relationships. That's going to spin, you know, that sort of intersection out in
different directions, but it's not representational. It's, it's, it's the town that lives in another town
or lives in the town.
That's right. No, no, no. But that's, that's right. Like it's not the difference between multiple
perspectives on the same town and the non-existence of a town, right? Like, uh, I mean that, you know,
the, the first way is the way that we, all of us always understand it, which is there is a glass
or whatever the thing that you picked up, like there is a mug. And then there are a whole bunch of
different perspectives on that mug. So you can see the same thing in different ways.
A little pun on the, you know, um, but that, that's something very different than saying
there's no glass, right? Right. There, there is only the perceiving, uh, or, or whatever. And,
and that's, that's all that the, or rather the glass is nothing other than the acts of perceiving.
There isn't a same, same thing there expression is that, you know, the, the glass is the expression
of a sensory apparatus, physical apparatuses, conceptual apparatuses, the intersection of all
of those apparatuses, you know, expresses glass, but it doesn't cause glass. Right. And in that sense,
in that sense, glass is event, right? The, the glass is an expressed event to glass.
And the little, the little, the, the thing you did earlier too, like where, like, the, the mug or the
glasses is incompatible with the coaster. I mean, that's like, if incompatibility is thought at the
level of identity, then that would be true, right? Like they are incompatible, but what Deleuze is
after is the expressibility of the event. When, in which case the glass is not a glass and the coaster is
not a coaster. They're both a collection or series of events that contribute them at a molar level to
be like actualized as those things. But at a differential register, you have to think of them
differently. Right. I always find the time, the time, the glass and the glass. And that, and that's
where like, you know, for me, for instance, like one of the things that keeps recurring, because I tend
to think of events as things that happen and that's wrong. Like, but it recurs to me every time when I'm
trying to think, okay, what does he mean by an event here? And I think like, oh, you know, the 4th of
July or a birthday or what, you know, like I think of it as things that we conventionally, colloquially
will call an event. But then there are these moments in here where he's like, you know, an event is an
entire life or an event is an entire epoch. Like, I mean, the time span of events is not a day or a
minute or whatever. It can be. Can be. Right. But birthdays can be events. Crossing the Rubicon
is an event, but that doesn't mean that a life isn't or the moment of the human isn't.
Right. That's why it's helpful to think spatially, I think, because the event is, is the surrounding,
right? It's a surrounding in which something gets constituted. Right. Right. Yeah. I mean,
I just hesitate on surrounding because it sounds. Not surrounding as in like it surrounds it,
but like it's the vicinity of the thing in which, in which that thing. Yeah. Proximity. You could
say the intersection of the thing because that wouldn't include an enclosed space because those
lines are now connecting to a bunch of other things, but a bunch of things, you know, cross
in such a way that you call it Caesar crosses the Rubicon or a glass. Right. Right. Right.
But thinking of these terms spatially or physically, I think definitely helps. Like expression is a
material phenomenon. It's contraction and protraction between relations or, you know, it's hard not to
use terms that kind of get calcified into identities. We have to. We have to. Right. But that's what's
happening. It's not the expression of a prior identity through language, which would be elbow. Right.
It's the expression of relations. That's right. This is an expression with no medium, with no
understanding, with no representation. Right. Like the glass is an expression of sets of relations.
One of the things that I keep coming back to is we're heading, we head down this, this kind of road
we're, and I don't know if I feel like this is a cop out move, but like, you know, this sort of points
to, um, or the Hegelian organization points to the limits of human consciousness, right? Like in other
words, the, the, our capacity to live in the sort of body's depth arena, which is where we live. Right.
And, and, and that association of causality, like there is no getting out of that. And, and it's
because of a kind of limitation, which is human consciousness. And so to that extent, I would say
Hegel is just the most brilliant thinker of human consciousness, which is precisely why it needs to
be overcome. I mean, that's where Nietzsche, for me, the Nietzschean line is the task of the task,
the only task worthwhile is overcoming the human. You know, that's the Superman, the overman or whatever,
you know, translation, like that's the Nietzschean, uh, offering. And it's, it's precisely in this sense
of, yeah, of course, we're holding onto the representational and the logical and the causal
relations and, and pointing to something that is irreducible to those simultaneously, but only
because out that's what our particular organisms and how they operate so that we, we can't, we have to
speak in the language of identities because there's not another, there's not another language, but that's
a, that's our problem, not life's. But we also operate at the level of event and the surface as
well. Like, I mean, take the sentence that we already read. Of course. You know, the self, the self
merges with the very disjunction, which it liberates and places outside of itself in that
divergence series with blah, blah, blah, blah. Right. Well, here's, here is a divergence that gets,
you know, affirmed or liberated the marriage of the, of the human and human consciousness and binary
representational thinking. And look at the way that that, you know, the, the liberation and the,
the sort of, you know, expression of that, what that has done to the world. Right. Like,
you know, that's not, again, that's not like, you know, one sphere that we, you know, that,
that, that we live in, or it's not a transcendent law that operates over things. It is like,
that is just an expression of a, of, of, of a series of divergences that has taken on.
Right. We're just the gray, the gray butterfly. We're the gray butterfly. Yeah. You know, I mean,
Or, or the black, it doesn't matter which one you pick, but that's just sort of what we are. And
it's not a question of it being better or worse, you know, and, or inadequate or in not vigorous
enough. It's just, that's just how it works and it'll become something else. Yeah. Or it won't.
Yeah. Yeah. I don't know. I find, I mean, I find that really like, I, I find that thought
super comforting. Yeah. And, um, I don't know why, but I also feel like it is a bit of a cop out,
like just to say, well, that's just how humans think, right? Like, is that we are,
we are wedded to this thing. We, we can sense that there's something other than this thing,
which is logic, causality, depth, state of affairs being right. We, we sense that there's
something other than that. And that's a dimension of our, frankly, I would even say experiential life,
right? Like, in other words, I, I, I think that all these are like, when you try to talk about things
like inspiration or being in the zone and all these kinds, you know, like that, that to me,
those kinds of experiential things point to like, there's something else in terms of our relations,
you know, that, that creates different types of possibilities, but we simply don't have a way
of thinking of it.
I don't need to understand the zone to get into it.
No. In fact, it's counter. I mean, you know, understanding, like once consciousness is involved,
the likely, I mean, there's a reason they call it being unconscious, right? Like he,
you know, uh, is, is precisely because it's not organized around understanding.
Even when it happens in conscious, right? Like we've all been in the zone with our thinking
and our writing, which we would at one level definitely call like a conscious activity.
But if you start reflecting on the in the zoneness of that conscious writing,
you fucked it all up, right? You, you just wrote your last paragraph.
But see, I mean, but that's a counter argument that Nate, I think that you want to take up,
right? Because that increasing self-consciousness can be a limit, right? Like it can be a limiting
force. Like, in other words, it can interrupt other kinds of, um, I don't know, possibilities,
whatever.
Or another thing to say is just like, look, self-reflection is not in a special place.
Self-reflection is just, is it, is it, is it's own possible? There's a possibility for your own
self-reflection zone, right? Right. So it's not that, you know, if you think about being in the zone
and then the meta-reflection of the zone, you know, and then that, that fucks with it. No, it's, it's,
it's not, it's not the meta-reflection of the thing. It's just a different, um, um,
wavelength that has been introduced to this in the zoneness. And then now it's just taking you to a
different zone. Now you might not like that and you might wish that you were still in the first zone.
Or you might, or you might like it. Or you might like it. I mean, we, I think we talked about that
in one of the episodes is like, look, self-awareness is self-awareness that meta-level
cognition in terms of thinking is for me an incredibly enjoyable experience. Like I like doing that. I like
being self-aware of how, of the directions that my thinking is going and it allows, it allows me
possibilities in terms of, uh, different kinds of things. So, but, but again, that's not because
I have some, what, higher understanding or some increased control of my, uh, possibilities,
you know? Well, in a lot of ways, it's a relinquishing of control. I mean, allowing meta-reflection
to kind of, to do some sort of movement, that's relinquishing control. I mean, you're not,
you're not, I mean, when I do that, when I try to, you know, explore, uh, the, like the flights
of thinking, like that can lead to incoherence. But see, that's why, that's why it can't be
meta-reflection then. Right? Like we have to come up with a different term. So, I mean, I agree
with you 100%. Yeah. But what, and what we understand ourselves as doing is always being reflective,
which means, right? Like, or, or some meta level, but, but what we're actually doing is not
meta-reflecting. We're following lies. As you just said, we're following lies. Right. Yeah.
Yeah. Go back to like meta as in that. No, it's just the thing next to it. And, and, and getting to
this point was spurred by the last thing and spurred by a certain practice that we call better
reflection. Right. But I don't, yeah, I don't have a height. I don't have a, right. I don't have a
Heightened understanding of my action because I'm meta-reflected. Right. I don't have a
height advantage, but, but that there is, but that there is a compatibility among those two
thoughts, which is, you know, thought one and meta-reflection two are not, they're not just
different thoughts. Right. There's a compatibility between those two thoughts, but it is not one of
heightened awareness. So it's, that's the mistake is to think of it in terms of levels,
but conversely, it's not, there's not no relation among them either.
I have fallen prey a little bit to the temptation of thinking about them also as being able to be in
contact too, which I think he would be like, no, no, there's no actual contact. There's no actual
touching. Right. But I do think of those things as like the, the thought and the meta thought
touching each other, but they can't. So, I mean, I think it's interesting also to like keep them also
on different lines that like, they don't, they, they diverge, like physically diverge, like they just
will never touch quite. But in another sense, it seems like all they do is touch, right? Is that
because there's not the height difference. I mean, I think I, I, I take what you're saying in the sense
that you're saying it, but I think there's another sense in which, you know, the meta thought,
that, you know, never becomes disconnected and never gets, you know, that, that height
differentiation. It's only, you know, it's, it's, it is in some ways just as much connected to what
came before it as, as, you know, it would be if you would have stuck in, in, in the zone.
Without being, without being self-identical. So that, this is again, the problem is, so how do
you represent that? And every attempt, so Caddy just attempted to physically and spatially
represent it. And then you're like, well, yeah, but they're not two different things. It's like,
yeah, you know, they're not. So they, they are, and they aren't, you know?
But, but that's the nice thing about the word sense in all of this and the thinking of sense in
all of this is that in trying to, yeah, the, the, the, the project of making differentiations
that can get you to the precise absolute representation of something is just a folly is
that, you know, the value of oppositions or descriptions or expositions or whatever else
is only to sort of like render the idiosyncrasy of a sense to its fullest level that in no way
opposes the possibility of different perspectives of different, you know, senses. This clicked
with me is, is holding up the water glass and realizing that this is simultaneously in different
senses and different, you know, not the sort of like the normal way we think of perspective,
but like the more ontological sense of perspective, this glass is both a body and an event at the
same time. It is the eventing glass and then also a composition of, of, of, of bodies.
This is, this is where the, the Spinoza lesson, we don't yet know what a body can do,
right? Like as, as the mantra, not because we haven't figured it out yet, right? Like not
because we'll get there in a hundred years or something, but it's like, no, that's a constitutive
dimension of our relation to bodies is we don't, we can't yet know. And the, the, so the command in
that sense, speaking of the town example is make more towns, right? I mean, make more towns. I mean,
that's what we're going to be doing. Right. Um, so just don't think that you are just gaining
another perspective on the same thing.